[Music]
this animation shows how China's leader
Xi Jinping Consolidated power within the
Communist Party by stacking it with
loyalists and how he broke some key
long-standing party rules in order to do
so it's based on a Bloomberg News
analysis of appointments of the
Communist Party Central Committee since
1992 some
1300 appointments so far the Communist
party's leadership is made up of more
than 300 officials divided in a
five-level hierarchy at the top of
course is the General Secretary of Xi
Jinping who also serves as the president
and commander-in-chief of the Communist
party's military
below him is the Supreme seven-man
standing committee the 25-member top
decision-making pilot Bureau and then
the much larger Central Committee and
his alternates each Congress provides
the opportunity to rejig the ranks while
China has denied having a retirement age
for top Communist Party officials no one
has breached 68 in the upper ranks of
power for decades but now at 69 she is
expected to secure a precedentifying
third term going past that age cap
two other members of the current signing
committee are also due to age out under
that rule whether she breaks that Norm
just for himself or for the other two as
well remains to be seen
[Music]